Десятки тисяч полеглих і покалічених воїнів з обох боків,
тисячі загиблих цивільних українських громадян, незліченна кількість зруйнованих міст в Україні.
До цього можна додати глобальний дефіцит енергоносіїв, інфляцію та голод у багатьох країнах, що розвиваються.
Це - наслідки війни, яка й через рік після початку досі не завершилася.
Президент Росії Володимир Путін не зміг досягти своєї мети повністю захопити Україну.
Однак Росія окупувала приблизно п'яту частину країни.
Президент України Володимир Зеленський, натомість, неодноразово заявляв,
що всі окуповані Росією території, включно з Кримом, будуть відвойовані.
У військовому плані українцям вдалося дещо відтіснити росіян.
Вони звільнили понад 50 відсотків території, яку росіяни окупували ще в лютому.
Адже, за різними оцінками, під час бойових дій було вбито або поранено близько 200 тисяч російських солдатів.
І ці цифри, схоже, зростають дуже високими темпами протягом останнього місяця,
коли російські війська кидають людей хвиля за хвилею в атаку навколо Бахмута.
Україна зможе звільнити ще більше своїх територій, вважає американський експерт Чарльз Капчан,
старший експерт Ради з міжнародних відносин.
Проте можливість повернення всіх окупованих територій Україною
експерт пов'язує з можливою подальшою ескалацією.
Я вважаю, що Україна зможе повернути більше територій.
Але є ймовірність того, що ми побачимо таку собі патову ситуацію
замість повного відновлення територіального суверенітету України.
І я також вважаю, що зусилля України повернути Крим силою
насправді значно підвищать ризик ескалації - як територіальної, тобто ширшої війни,
так і вертикальної ескалації, можливого використання Росією ядерної зброї.
Останнім часом здавалося, що ядерна риторика Кремля пішла на спад.
Але останнє раптове рішення Кремля призупинити найважливіший договір
щодо контролю за ядерною зброєю шокувало західних експертів з озброєнь.
Після початку повномасштабної війни низка країн НАТО та ЄС
ввели санкції проти Росії. Утім, санкції не мали такого сильного впливу
на російську економіку, як очікувалося, вважає Стівен Пайфер,
експосол США в Україні, експерт Академії Роберта Боша.
Тим не менше, експерт переконаний - вплив від санкцій на російську економіку
ставатиме дедалі відчутнішим. Як і подальша ізоляції Росії.
Геополітично подивіться, що сталося. Швеція та Фінляндія,
дві країни, які мали давні традиції нейтралітету, зараз прагнуть
і подали заявку на вступ до НАТО. Отже, коли я дивлюся на цю війну,
то думаю, що врешті-решт це стало катастрофою для Росії.
Володимир Путін, його его настільки прив’язане до цієї війни, що Кремлю важко шукати альтернативний курс.
Чи вдасться Україні перемогти Росію у військовому плані,
залежатиме від того, якою буде подальша військова підтримка України
західними партнерами, переконаний Штефан Майстер з Німецького товариства зовнішньої політики.
Адже, на його думку, Росія все ще має достатньо сильну економіку,
щоб інвестувати у війну в найближчі 2-3 роки.
Росію можна було б перемогти у суто військовому сенсі, тобто вигнати її з України,
якби Захід справді втрутився військовим шляхом.
Я думаю, що тоді Росія була б переможена.
Те, як зараз здійснюється підтримка західних країн,
в тому числі і розвідувальними даними, недостатньо для того,
щоб Україна виграла цю війну і вигнала Росію зі своєї території.
Я вважаю, що зараз важливо, щоб Україна не програла війну
і відвоювала деякі території, але того, що дають західні партнери у підсумку недостатньо.
Наразі Україна отримала від західних партнерів лише чверть від обіцянного останніми місяцями озброєння.
В Україні наголошують, що західна зброя необхідна вже зараз,
аби суттєво змінити ситуацію на полі бою.
Це дасть українським військовим насамперед можливість впевнено воювати
в наступні кілька місяців, знаючи, що будуть надходження західної зброї,
яка компенсує будь-які втрати, яких українська армія
може зазнати в найближчі два-три місяці.
Це надасть їм, я думаю, дуже потужні можливості.
Танки "Абрамс", танки "Леопард" - дуже ефективні,
і це дало б українцям, я вважаю, розширену здатність проводити контрнаступи,
щоб вибити російську армію з території України.
Це все зброя. Але що насправді стане вирішальним фактором, так це рішучість,
мужність, майстерність та новаторство українських військових.
І вони вже це показали протягом останнього року.
Закінчення війни не військовим шляхом,
а шляхом мирних переговорів найближчим часом експерти оцінюють скептично,
адже наразі обидві сторони вірять у можливий прогрес на полі бою.
Президенту Зеленському вдалося досить успішно переконати союзників по НАТО
не просто продовжувати поставки зброї, а й підвищити їхній рівень.
Тож поки що я думаю, що бої будуть продовжуватись.
Я вважаю, що десь протягом 2023 року, можливо, наприкінці літа чи восени,
ми дійдемо до моменту, коли Україна та Росія можуть вирішити,
що вони не в змозі досягти подальшого прогресу на полі бою.
І саме в цей момент, я думаю, дипломатія зможе досягти певного прогресу.
Як може виглядати якесь дипломатичне врегулювання?
Дуже важко сказати. Я думаю, що одним з елементів цього буде рішення України
прийняти нейтралітет, озброєний нейтралітет.
Тому що ми бачимо, як НАТО озброює Україну, аби Росія не могла досягти успіху
і ніколи не спробувала напасти знову.
Для Заходу зараз було б розумніше надати Україні більше зброї,
надати Україні такі інструменти, щоб Україна змогла або витіснити росіян найближчим часом,
або досягти достатнього прогресу на полі бою і щоб Кремль вирішив,
що він має вести серйозні переговори.
Але я говорю про переговори, які могли б привести до врегулювання на умовах, які Україна могла б прийняти.
Експерти переконані: швидкого закінчення війни не буде.
А подальша зміна ситуації на полі бою залежатиме насамперед від військової підтримки західних партнерів.